good morning members
good morning members of the public
you're very welcome here this morning
the baby district council's planning
committee
may i first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
if you wish to speak
or a point of order or declaration
of interest or requesting as german
please use the hands up
function on the taskbar
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open other other teams chats
and that if you are contacted by a third
party
during an application you should bring
this to the legal advisor's attention
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked
to leave if members do lose connection
to the meeting please would they
contact the member support officer mandy
smith as soon as possible
we will be using modern.gov to conduct
all electronic votes during the meeting
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast
live to the internet and will be capable
of repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes the councils
members of the public and press may
record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
thank you i'd like to introduce you to
the following officers
area planning manager mark russell
planning lawyer
indie governor oh sorry
governor's officer is claire philpart
case officer samantha summers sarah
scott
and jasmine weinmark
now i'll move to the agenda item number
one
apologies for absence and substitutions
do we have any
okay thank you chair right
apologies we have apologies from
councillor melanie barrett
and councillor alison owen and
councillor sean dawson is substituting
for councillor barrett
all right thank you very much
the rest of us are all present are there
any decorations of interest by members
to be declared
no right we'll move to item number three
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the
7th of april they've been sent through
hopefully you've all had a chance to
have a read of them
can i ask are there any points of
accuracy
i see no hands going up so if not
then can i ask for for somebody to
propose
uh counselor airs yes i propose that we
accept them
thank you chair and do i have a second
to please
oh well there's no one i'll second them
then
um i've seconded them
right i'll never ask the
government officer to take us through
the electronic vote
thank you claire can you
take us through that please yes thank
you chair councillors on your mod gov
app
please select the plus sign on the top
right and then select attendance and
voting
followed by voting the vote for this
item should now show in progress
and in a light blue color
yes that's correct
and then close
just waiting i think sorry i think i
remember the correct order that time so
i think i've got to the end
okay yeah i'm just waiting for one vote
councillor dawson would you like me to
take your vote verbally
yes i can't get it open um
four okay that's brilliant thank you
very much
uh chair so that's 10 votes for that's
unanimous
thank you very much right then we can
move on
um item number four is the notification
of any petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
um claire non-received chair
thank you very much site inspections
officers are there any site inspection
requests
number safe chair thank you very much
members are there any site inspection
requests
no thank you i'll then move on
to item number six and that's
on page 11 and
um the officer samantha summers and mrs
burroughs arms
if you'd like to take us through
samantha thank you very much chair i'll
just pop
my uh presentation up for you
if you could tell me when you can see it
please yes
we can say it and i can hear you lovely
that's great
okay right um good morning everyone
this application comes to committee as
it is considered to be contentious
there have been 55 letters of support a
petition
was received with 530 signatures
that this has been invalidated which is
why the governance officer has not
mentioned it
previously the petition was in support
of the application
there has been one letter of objection
objection um objections have been
received from
oxford parish council the heritage team
and the landscape officer
the application seeks full planning
permission for
the erection of six bungalows and five
holiday
cabins on land adjacent to the brewers
arms public house
in bauer house thai polsted
this is the application site shown in
the hatched area
the public house is located on the a
1071
which links sudbury to hadley and
ipswich
the public house sits on the edge of a
small cluster of dwellings in bauer
house thai
just here there is a touring caravan
site to the south of the site
just here bauer house thai
does not have a built-up area boundary
and is classified as countryside in the
local plan
two appeals the single dwellings have
been dismissed in recent years
one at walnut cottage within the cluster
of bauhaus thai
and the other one at miracle barn
just located outside of the cluster the
inspector found
that the location was not suitable for
new housing
this shows the small cluster of
dwellings in bauer house thai
the only facilities within the cluster
are the public house
which is located at the bottom here with
a triangular
shape and uh the bus stops
the cluster is located in a very rural
setting and you can see all the fields
surrounding the area
this shows the site in a little bit more
detail
this is the public house building just
here it has a beer garden here
the children's play area formal parking
with uh the access point here and some
informal
overflow parking in this section here
the application site like it is located
on agricultural land
which is classed as grade 2 agricultural
and
grade two land is considered to be very
good quality land for generally a high
uh lee yield level
there are very mature trees and
hedgerows along the field boundaries to
the north
and also to the west
polsted has three different built up
area boundaries
uh one imposted heath which is a small
cluster here
one in white street green another
cluster
and then in polsted village itself
the main facilities for the village
including
a shop and church and another public
house are all located
in this area of polsted other facilities
that are close
to bauer house thai are located uh
in boxford and in hadley
and that's where you'll find shops um
doctor surgeries
and those type of facilities and schools
there is no pedestrian link on made up
footpaths
with street lighting which would link
the uh bauer house tie to boxford
and actually you would need to walk
along
a 60 mile an hour speed limit road in
order to gain access to boxford which is
two and a half kilometers away
the distance to the day-to-day
facilities is considered to be
unsustainable for residents
and they would require the use of a
motor vehicle in order to gain access
to those day-to-day facilities
it is noted that in the emerging joint
local plan the application
site is outside of the settlement
boundary which also
excludes the access to the public house
which is here
so the new uh settlement boundary would
just be around
the cluster of dwellings and the public
house itself but no land that belongs to
the public house other than the beer
garden
in the joint local plan uh paul the
bauer house thai
is classified as a hamlet and that would
mean
that the kind of developments that would
be acceptable
would be small infills uh over
either single detached dwellings or a
pair of semi-detached dwellings but that
would be
within the settlement boundary itself
this is the site location plan the red
line shows the site
using the existing access point to the
public house
the blue ownership line is actually
incorrect and
includes the public house and this land
here
that isn't actually correct and you will
find
a corrected plan in your addendum papers
it will also be shown on a later slide
in this presentation
it is quite important to understand the
land ownership
when deciding this application the
applicant is the owner of the public
house
he owns the access point only
the application site and further
agricultural fields belong to a separate
land owner
members should bear in mind that
planning permission is attached to the
land
not the applicant and the part of the
development
can be built out whilst other parts not
coming forward
for example the dwellings could be
built out and the holiday cabins may not
be built out
there are two listed buildings near to
the site both the grade two listed
we have thatcher's house in this
location here
and homewood cottages which are the
nearest neighbors to the public house
just here
this is the existing site layout showing
the proposed access point
through the pub car park and through the
children's play area and
into the field beyond
this just shows the uh the visibility
displays and
uh suffolk county council highways have
not objected to the application
this application has been received
following pre-application advice and
also
a previous application that was
withdrawn
uh is for the same scheme of six
dwellings and five holiday cabins
this shows the layout of the previous
application where the dwellings were
filling this section of the field with
the holiday cabins
just around here
the the previous application was
withdrawn
because heritage concerns were raised on
the setting
of the listed buildings of homewood
cottages and thatcher's house
as well as issues around sustainability
the scheme for the current application
remains the same but is located slightly
south of the previous position
so the houses have been pushed down to
be almost in line with the public house
itself
taking it away from these listed
buildings
the red line site has been divided into
two sections
and you might be able to see this faint
uh dotted
red line that goes around the
residential area
the rest of the site is uh for a beer
garden
extension to the public house and the
holiday cabins
parking area and a public recreation
space just here
the uh this area here that is in the
hatched area
has been defined as residential by the
applicant
and this is to avoid an affordable
housing contribution
this area of residential development
falls just below
0.5 hectares and does not trigger
affordable housing
to try and address heritage concerns a
woodland grove is proposed
as a landscaping belt between the listed
buildings
and the development
[Music]
in this area just here however
the heritage team still have concerns
as the morphology of the cluster of the
existing dwellings in bauer house type
thai is compromised by the separation
of this development from the actual
cluster
within bauer house tie the development
forms a bulge in the countryside which
sticks out
this development is not considered to
relate well to the existing bauer house
thai
cluster less than substantial harm has
been identified to the setting of the
heritage assets
public benefits of the scheme are very
limited as there is no affordable
housing contribution
and therefore public benefits are not
considered to outweigh the harm
in terms of the holiday cabins they
would bring some public benefit to the
local economy
with provision of tourist accommodation
and a small number of
jobs the argument has been made that the
dwellings are required so that the
landowner
can hand over land for the pub for the
holiday cabins
to the public house who owns the access
point
this is an informal agreement that has
no planning grounds
and because a planning permission
benefits the land
it cannot be guaranteed that the
development before you
can be delivered as you see it on this
plan
the only beneficiary would be the
landowner not necessarily the public
house
to try and overcome issues of
sustainability
an informal footpath through a
wildflower meadow
which you may be able to see just in
this area here is quite faint
has been proposed which would link to a
public right-of-way to the west of the
site
this is not considered to be acceptable
to access day-to-day
facilities in boxford particularly
during wet and dark months of the year
the landscape officer has also had the
same concerns
as the heritage officer with the
separation of the existing cluster from
the proposed development
concerns were also raised about the very
suburban layout of the dwellings
with this uh very straight and angular
appearance
this conflicts with the locally
distinctive
character of bauer house thai which has
a very loose pattern of development
and is quite organic in the way that is
set out
concerns were also raised by
environmental protection
about the extension of the beer garden
in this location here
and the proximity to the new dwellings
the pub has a quite unusual license
which allows it to be open until 1 30 at
the weekends
and could cause disturbance to the
residents
of the proposed development the
applicant
has stated that the dwellings would be
for the over 55s
there is concern that the location which
is not well
connected to amenities is not a suitable
place for older people to live
residents particularly as they get older
could feel quite isolated in this
location
four three bedroom bungalows are
proposed and two
two bedroom bungalows these are the
drawings of the two bedrooms
and this is the drawings of the
three-bedroom bungalow
each dwelling would have a single garage
some are linked
so that they have the appearance of a
double garage and some are
single
three two bedroom holiday cabins are
proposed
and uh two three-bedroomed cabins
moving on to the photographs this is
from the access point
uh looking south towards the box bridge
direction
this is looking north from the access
point in the hadley direction and you
can just see
on the on the left of the picture there
the bus stop
which is directly outside of uh the
public house
uh this is looking into the public uh
public house car park uh with the
children's play area
you can just see some equipment just
there
the access point to the field would just
go through this area here
[Music]
this is looking at the car parking area
of the car park
and the overflow area which forms that
pointed shape just at the bottom
the south of the site
this is the bruised arms public house
and you can see the
beer garden just here the access point
here on the right hand side which would
cut across here and into the field
beyond
this is the field from the access point
through the play area
looking south towards the boxford
direction
this is looking in the opposite
direction where the listed buildings are
so we have patch's house
in this creamy color and then homewood
cottages are behind this hedgerow here
this area here is uh proposed as the
woodland glade area
again you can just see thatcher's house
here
and the area of the proposed woodland
this is just a closer shot of thatcher's
house
uh you can see along the boundary the
mature hedge row and
the mature trees
this shows the mature trees along the
field boundary
uh to the west of the site this is a
very large agricultural field of good
quality soil
and is very open in the landscape
this is the top of homewood cottages and
the hedgerow
this is also grade two listed this is
the closest neighbor to the public house
just standing back a bit so this is the
uh
listed cottages with the public house
just to the right of the picture here
and so this area here would be the
woodland glade area
you can see the brewer's arms public
house here
and the access point would be through
here so
development would be from sort of this
line
and south running south along the field
again the public house and the very
large field
and this is the area proposed for the
development
the application is considered to be
inappropriate for new housing
bauer house tie is a small cluster of
dwellings that does not have a built up
area boundary
and is therefore considered to be
countryside
development in this area is contrary to
policy cs2 of the baby core strategy
connectivity to nearest facilities would
be in boxford
which is a two and a half kilometer walk
along a 60 mile an hour
road with no footpath
two refused applications for housing
close to the site have been appealed
shown with the red dots
both were dismissed on sustainability
grounds
the site is outside of the settlement
boundary in the joint local plan
less than substantial harm has been
identified by the heritage team because
of harm to the setting of the listed
buildings
but also the morphology of the cluster
of powerhouse tie
the public house um
oh sorry the public benefits of six new
dwellings
added to the land supply but no
affordable housing contribution
does not outweigh the harm the public
benefits of the holiday that's
supporting the pub
cannot be guaranteed because the pub
does not own the land
the pub does have space in its own land
for one or two
or maybe two holiday cabins without
having to extend into the countryside
a case has been made that this
application will help recovery from
covet restrictions on the business
however the same scheme was brought
forward in 2019
before the pandemic it is noted from
objectives
that the pub has not been open at all
during the last year
and has done nothing to help itself with
providing takeaway services
or other services for local people the
pub has remained closed
even though outdoor restrictions have
been lifted at the current time
in terms of landscape harm the
development forms a bulge
into the countryside which you can
clearly see
from from this drawing
which is detached from bauhaus thai
and spatially does not sit comfortably
within the landscape
the suburban layout of straight lines is
not reflected
reflective of existing development which
has a much looser pattern of development
in bauer house thai
baba has an identified need for smaller
lifetime dwellings
it is proposed that six bungalows would
be for the over 55s
however because of poor connectivity to
services and amenities it is likely that
older people
may find themselves isolated and lonely
concerns of residential immunity for
future residents has been raised by
environmental protection
the proposed extension to the beer
garden would share a boundary with some
of the bungalows
the pub has a licence to serve until 1
30 am
a weekend there is no guarantee that the
scheme can be delivered
in the way it has been presented because
of the land ownership issues
there is a risk that dwellings would be
allowed
in a countryside location without the
pub having any benefits
for these reasons the application is
recommended for refusal
sustainability grounds heritage harm
landscape harm
and potential harm to residential
immunity for future residents thank you
yeah i'll take them down
that's better i think no
sam can i just suggest you turn off your
mic and then the echo will probably go
thank you chair
ah that's better it's not echo and you
don't want to hear me twice
and everything do you remember right
members
um you've heard the um case presented by
uh the case officer is there any points
of clarification that you
wish to ask her
it does seem um samantha quite messy
from the
ownership point of view can you just um
explain that a little bit again because
uh quite often we have applications come
forward
from developers or applicants who want
to build somewhere
and they've usually got a i assume a
signed
agreement with the owners that if they
were
fortunate enough to get planned
permission a b and c would happen is
this not the case
um to my knowledge it's just as
gentleman's agreement at the moment
so uh the landowner who owns a field
requires access through the pub car park
which is a ransom strip effectively
in order to gain access to the land so
there is an agreement
but it is informal and that has no uh
planning basis
to my knowledge there is not any option
to purchase the land
by the applicant but maybe this is
something that ian duprey might be
able to cast more light on i'll
ask the um solicitor can you just come
in
can you help on that yes indeed
obviously
um planning law and land ownership are
two separate issues but then
clearly sometimes maybe this is one such
case where
land ownership has a practical
consequence for the delivery of a
planning permission if there if it is
if the wish is to grant it and obviously
the recommendations not to in this case
so that i think we would need to if the
decision
the discussion committee took a certain
turn we might need to have regard to the
practical issues arise from this
um the ransom strip situation that sam
has just described thank you thank you
very much
uh i've uh can i can't see any hands up
can you see any claire
yes i believe councillor parker has his
hand up all right
thank you councillor parker
good morning um sam i wonder if i could
just could you just confirm for
them or otherwise mark what is our
current five-year
land housing supply position please
uh yes it is 6.64 years
thank you very much right i can see
councillor dawson's hand that's up
um yes sorry if you could just clarify
this bit about the um
ransom the the access
um does this mean that the landing is
presumably wanting to use
that as an access point for his tractors
going into
the s agricultural land
through this site why would he want
why would he why would the landowner
want access
other than does that not seem rather
yeah so yes the um
the access point would only be
for the development itself so for the
six bungalows
and for the five holiday cabins but did
you sorry say that the
landowner requires wants to maintain
ownership access rights so presumably
that is is that what you said sorry
no so um they only want to access
if the development goes ahead
but if it goes ahead does that mean the
sorry
does that mean i'm sorry can i help here
i think you're saying
can they continue this access to get to
the field
the other side of this area if it's
built
why does the land owner want access
through
that site when it's built no it's only
into the site i believe is that correct
samantha
yes that's correct is it not through
that site onto his own land
no i i would imagine that there is
another access point for the
agricultural field which is an
agricultural
access so why does he want access onto
that side
he only wants access for the development
itself
yes why so there's any way you can get
to it if you look at the plan in front
of you
but why would the farmer who owns the
land want to get onto that site
okay
all right don't worry don't worry thank
you mr chairman
yeah yes perhaps the uh
yeah the agricultural access is too far
away from the proposed development for
it to be used
because obviously because he's obviously
been using it because the field's been
plowed
yeah but why would you as you would if
you were the farmer
what to drive in there when that's been
hanging out
you're getting into debate yeah okay
this is clarification
i think you could put this question to
the applicant later on
a councillor dawson yeah um my
understanding is
that the right of way is purely from the
main road
through the existing car park and then
going
into this new hatched area that is
correct
there's no access through to the field
beyond
right okay um
let me have a look where are we all
right i don't know where my fins all
come out colored
um kenzler busby is next
yes and the the two appeals that were
turned down
how recently were they uh one in 2018
and one in 2019 okay thank you
thank you i've got no other hands up
so i'm assuming there's no more
questions for clarification
um so if that's the case we'll move on
and i'll now ask go to public speakers
uh we don't have the parish council uh
they've
got no one present but we have an
objector to speak mr andrew renshaw
you say i have three minutes in which to
address the committee
if you'd like to turn your camera on and
your microphone on
we haven't started the timer yet so
you're okay
um
[Music]
screen can you take down your screen um
samantha
we'll share on it still
right now i should right i can now see
you
and um i think i can hear counselor
dawson can you just turn your
camera off thank you
okay do you need to start yeah yes when
you're ready sir
okay uh thank you very much good morning
uh my name is andrew renshaw
i'm the bear and i've lived at
thatcher's house a grade two listed
building
for the past 20 years our entire
southern boundary
abuts the proposed development i must
firstly say that i'm surprised we're
considering this application today
given the fact that it does not comply
with national existing or emerging local
policy
and the development would cause harm to
two grade two listed buildings
i speak on behalf of a number of
residents of bauhaus thai many of whom
find the application complex and
confusing the application is made by the
owner of the pub
however the exception with exception of
the access way the development is
entirely on farmland and by mr keeble a
local builder
as stated by the planning officer this
approach significantly reduces the
ability of the planning authority
to ensure that the stated benefits to
the development are achieved
such as the wooded area and wildflower
meadow as they're conveniently outside
the red line of the development
do not farm part of the application my
objection
is for the following reasons i do not
consider the pub will close without
these holiday cabins
the argument has been made for the last
two years i am not aware of any other
business initiatives the applicant has
taken
to enhance his business the existing
ensuite accommodation at the pub is only
used infrequently by tradespeople
the applicant lives elsewhere the pub
has been closed all this year
with no takeaway food service and
remains closed until 19th may
despite having a large outside seating
area there is in fact room for two
cabins on the applicant's land
and if sympathetically designed i would
have no objection to this
finally no viability assessment has been
provided
therefore disregarding the smoke screen
of the pub we can focus on the proposed
six dwellings
which is effectively commercial
development for profit in the
countryside
firstly there's no housing need paper
has an excessive five-year land supply
the development is not sustainable and
is contrary to local national policies
because you need to drive anywhere to
the facilities of shops or health centre
et cetera
the late license the pub enjoys makes
adjacent residential development
inappropriate
your own policy requires exceptional
circumstances
um to justify development in the
countryside
the proposed scheme has been described
as being of an urban form
and the revised application proposed is
now remote and isolated from the cluster
of homes
and is detrimental to the rural
landscape therefore there is no
exceptional circumstances
i would also suggest that if the consent
were granted it would be an unhelpful
precedent
two grade two listed buildings will
suffer harm and their rural context
will be permanently lost they'll also
suffer a loss of amenity
due to public recreation in the woodland
the mitigating measure of woodland
together with the wildflower meadow
are outside of the development boundary
and there's no certainty the public
benefit from the holiday cabins
as they too lie outside the ownership of
the pub
in conclusion i cannot see any valid
reason to grant consent
but i can see many reasons to refuse
consent primarily
your own existence thank you mr renshaw
thank you
thank you i'll just see if you stay
there i'll see if there's any questions
from members to you
members have you got any questions you'd
like to ask the objector
uh councillor parker
yeah thanks again chad and good morning
mr renshaw
um i'm just if chair will allow this i'm
not sure but so
i'm just curious to know uh mr renshaw
um when we're reading through the
application
uh the support for the application seems
to be quite solid
55 letters of support and unusually
only one letter of objection and and
this committee would
uh would quite often uh see completely
the opposite of that but nonetheless
that that's that's the situation that
we've
uh that we've got at the moment so um
i mean even the parish council is
um um
well i i suppose really else is going to
ask if it was possible mr
i was going to ask mr mentioned opinion
of the fact that there is so much
support for this including
uh the parish council well
firstly i don't think there's support
from the parish council they have not
objected
uh so that's slightly different uh
you know they are they are also this is
a confusing application as
as one of your members uh found it
difficult to understand
the access arrangements and things it is
it is it is odd
uh because it it's confusing to pete i'm
a chartered surveyor and i i
i i'm sorry to interrupt you mr andrew
it's complex
answer his question i think a number of
people are confused by the nature of the
application and they feel intimidated
uh by the landowner many um houses
back on to land owned by mr kiebel and
they feel intimidated i speak for a
number of people but they
we do not wish to come forward there
were more objections in on the initial
application
but as i say people are confused and
they feel intimidated
um and um thank you i think you've
answered that
thank you uh thank you parker sorry to
interrupt you there
um the legal advisor was uh coming up
there did you wish to make any comments
all right jim
just see andrew on your on your
photograph i was just going to advise
that mr renshaw should be allowed to ask
and
answer the question in his own way but
he's done so that's quite all right by
me now thank you
thank you well done uh any other
questions for mr renshaw
no i can't say any hands up thank you
then mr ensure we'll move on we now have
a supporter
um perhaps if you can turn your camera
and mic off thank you
supporter mr sean davis
would you say like to come turn your
camera on and your microphone on
and you sir also have three minutes when
you're ready
okay good morning members of the
committee my name is sean davis and i'm
here to speak in support of the proposal
the bureau's arms is a much loved
facility and one which the village
cannot afford to lose
this is a village hub not just providing
a place for us to meet eat and drink but
also a home for a number of local groups
and clubs that would not survive without
it
we all know that public houses are being
lost on a daily basis yet mr marginson
is seeking to ensure that this
facility does not go the same way you
will see from the response from local
residents
that the risk of closure is very real
and that some development to secure the
fiscal
the facility is not unreasonable at all
i've followed the application closely
and seen the excessive levels of support
indeed this application has
unprecedented levels of support in the
local community
this includes the support of the parish
council who recognize the potential loss
of this asset to the village provides
sound reason to permit this development
to make sure the pub does not close and
eight immediate support letters
from neighbours and just one objection
from the hablar
the hamlet i do understand the planning
officer has a job to do and their
reasons for recommending refusal but
this is something that we simply cannot
afford to happen
in my view the weight to be given to
securing the future of the pub outweighs
all of the matters highlighted by the
planning officer
i'm aware there is a balanced judgment
to be made in making a decision on this
proposal
and urge you to give it the utmost
waiting to securing the future of the
public really
is critical at this community
the applicant and the landowner are
willing to provide the necessary
assurances through a legal agreement
as to the delivery of the holiday
accommodation and the woodland
and also the restriction of the
dwellings to parties for over 55s
the application is supported by a list
of 11 signatories of local people who
have registered their interest in living
at the proposed development
and these are all local people who meet
the over 55s threshold who wish to
relocate here if the development goes
ahead
i also endorse what the applicant has
said about the bus service this is
actually the most accessible part of
polstead and the only pulse dead bus
stops
and they have recently been upgraded the
bus service provider has confirmed in
writing that these are incredibly well
used stops
many local residents use the car part to
leave their vehicles whilst the but
whilst using the buses to hadley and
sudbury because they're not wanting to
drive to the tank
the bus stops are right outside the site
and it cannot be denied that this is the
most accessible part of polsted in that
regard
the development will deliver a small
number of much-needed homes
it will deliver holiday lets to support
the pub and open up the
access to the countryside and the new
woodland will also be a significant
benefit to the landscape and would
encourage ecology in the area
it is therefore my belief that the
benefits of this proposal
far outweigh any harm identified please
support this development and help
support this community
thank you very much thank you mr davis
i'll just service any questions from
members for you
uh members is then uh yes there's a
handgun up cancer
mclaren followed by councillor busby
good morning mr davis um
can you just explain to me i i'm a
counsellor of
um award and all the pubs of
sought to um make use of the
lifting of restrictions during what has
been a terrible year for hospitality
can you explain to me why the brewer's
arms you think has stayed
shut during all these lifting of
restrictions i have spoken to the owner
and um the reasoning behind it they they
opened
every opportunity they could with
indoors
but the outdoor offering is just the
amount of waste that i believe they've
had this year
the outdoor offering is no good at all
they will open as soon as they can with
indoor offering
um it creates waste and it's not viable
with the
with the overheads of the business and
extra staffing for
that sort of thing and i know that they
tried um
takeaway service um for two or three
weekends and it just wasn't viable
so but you would have to speak to mr
marginson for
but that's my understanding on it i know
that they want to open
but it's just not it's a case of
viability
and waste and with the waste they've
already had it's it's just not a viable
option
here at broward hashtag it's not a big
a big drinking pub it is an eating pub
and with the weather and everything else
i just don't think it would work for
them
okay thank you very much miss davis
councillor thanks
yes mr david she's you mentioned in the
words unprecedented levels of support
from locals yep why do you think
therefore that the pub
future will be dependent on half a dozen
holiday cabins and
a few bungalows already
as i said i'm not the owner you would
have to speak to him but i do know that
support for the pub is a very busy pub
but it is also
i think the the overheads and everything
else that are going up it's it's
it's it's another tie to the boat to try
and keep the place going another
another income stream if you like rather
than trying to build on a car park and
sell off a house or something silly like
that is something to sustain
the future of the pub rather than
chopping bits off and
getting rid of bits and that sort of
thing so but again mr martinson would
have to answer anything else i wouldn't
i wouldn't have a clue really
thank you uh councillor hinton
thank you chairman uh mr davis just a
quick one concerning you say that the
bus companies say that the
bus stop is uh very popular and is used
quite extensively
uh what are the timings of the buses
along that route when do they start in
the mornings and when do they finish in
the evenings um i believe
they start from around eight o'clock
before school time and they finish
around 5
30 they have been um
they're not as often as they were be
because since the coveted outbreak there
was obviously no one using the buses but
i believe they are hoping to get back to
the more regular service
um but as for times i think it's every
hour and a half or every
hour and 45 minutes
with cl with the bus finishing at half
past five then effectively the residents
would all be on an early evening curfew
well yes that's but that's the bus
service
in suffolk as far as i'm aware
thank you uh there's no other hands up
so i should take that that there's no
one other questions for you
thank you mr davis we'll move on to turn
your mic and camera off
and we'll move to the applicant mr mitch
marginson
you sir also have three minutes in which
to address the committee
and then ask if there's any questions
afterwards thank you
okay can everybody hear me uh yeah we
can't see you that way
we've only got your eyes and you got my
eyes
okay yeah yeah
that's about up there that's perfect
okay good morning chairman and members
this application is has been recommended
to be put in front of you today by
philip isabel the chief planning officer
this is a unique application offering a
wide spectrum of benefits recognized and
supported by many
and demonstrated by the amount of
supporting statements
this application is to secure the
viability of the brewer's arms
to secure the secure and increase
on-site employment
increase tourism to the area and tourist
spend consent
to continue supporting the pulsar
campsite which has no hospitality
facilities
to continue charity support and bottle
bank in a world place
good location supported by highways all
supporting
this valuable community help providing a
social wellbeing with home darts
cribbage and quiz teams
this application includes a total of six
small low-level bungalow dwellings
enclosed within the scheme to the rear
of the brewer's arms aimed at over 55 to
downsize
an opportunity to remain within the
parish in a small community
of like-minded people of similar age the
sale of this proportion of the scheme
shown by the red dotted line within
will generate the income required to pay
for the land and skin to be achieved and
delivered swiftly
whilst they understand the dwellings
initially appear to be outside planning
policy for being outside the settlement
boundary
have been designed have been designed
sympathetically
discreetly and enclosed to the rear of
the brewers arms and behind the on-site
living accommodation
and bed and breakfast accommodation to
protect and provide a buffer from any
bar or restaurant disturbance
i have been the i've had been at the
brewer's arms independent honor operator
since 2007
and to put this into some perspective
the industry is fragile and was before
the pandemic
with rising costs and continually
smaller margins
time has been running out on the
viability a statement from my accountant
has been applied to the application on
the portal
the pandemic has furthermore increased
debt and now without economic growth and
an additional income stream the brewer's
arms will be lost
lost to commercial office car sales
retail units or housing
the design and proposal adds to the
current offering i am not asking to
alter build on the car park or the beer
guard
i am asking for approval to complement
and improve the offering
with a proposal that has an overwhelming
level of 54
55 supporting statements includes eight
bauer housetown neighboring local
residents
including the nearest affected homeowner
in a sustainable location with regular
bus service on the doorstep
local taxi services and on-site charging
points for future proofing
and use of electrical vehicle
encouragement whilst being well placed
for a modern day
home delivery services i hope i have
demonstrated on it the exceptional
amount and overwhelming benefits this
proposal will bring
and great sadness if lost to conclude i
quote the baby chief economics officer
who stated i appear very focused on
investing in the future of the business
and doing everything i can to sustain
the future as a vital village asset
thank you for listening thank you
members is there any questions or
clarifications
that you wish to put counselor airs
thank you thank you um hello
and good morning um i was just wondering
um the
um thinking about the staff how many
staff do you employ are they local staff
um you know how they've been furloughed
what's been happening
okay we have 15 staff
they come from oxford polsted white
street green and hadley
all local people um they have been on
furlough
during the period of closure and at this
time
i understand or seeking to return
um when went back to normality or from
um when we can reopen the inside of the
building to
offer a full offering of service
right thank you and thank you thank you
very much chair
thank you thank you councillor parker
thank you chair i'll get straight to the
point this time mr martin
um good morning uh support for this
application mr martin is is predicated
upon
the survival of the brewers arms pub
predominantly so
given that mr keeble is actually the
landowner
um how does the erection of six private
dwellings
um help sustain the business of the
brewer's arms
that will fund this the the um
the landowner is prepared to offer the
land to support the borough's arms
when the applica if the application gets
accepted on that way the
development within the red dotted line
the bungalow development will be sold to
a developer which will have the access
through my entrance
to provide funding for the five holiday
lodges
uh to be an income stream to the brewers
arms
with the uh again a combination of the
uh the residents that then of the
holiday lodges
we'll also then be able to eat and eat
the brewer's arms
can i ask a second mr chair yes yes
okay so if that being the case going
back to the officer's
comments so um is there a legal
agreement in place to make that happen
right now is there or not
there is not the legal agreement right
now it has been offered
it's been offered um to be completed to
ensure that the whole development goes
together again
goes ahead as a whole without the access
without the holiday lodges
um the access just doesn't become
available because that supports my
viability
okay so there's no there's no legal
agreement in place that's what i needed
to know
thank you thank you any other hands up
no thank you uh
mr martin um if you'd like to turn your
camera mic off we'll move on
we now go to the ward member councillor
john ward you sir have five minutes in
which to address the committee
would you like to turn your camera and
mike on
yeah um
good hear you we can't see you should be
on see me now
it was just taking a while yes that's
right yeah
okay uh thanks um this is an application
for the construction of holiday cabins
and bungalows that the brewer's arms
posted
and we'll start by saying that i'm sure
you're all aware now that
it is a difficult application it has
come before the committee today because
there is a controversial element to it
and it has significant planning
considerations that need to be addressed
in an open debate
as you have heard the pub needs to
improve its offering to remain viable
and the provision of additional
accommodation in the form of holiday
cabins is being proposed
it is a good local business with
established pub teams and draws clear
and tell from a wide area
as well as visitors from the nearby
caravan park the applicant mr martinson
has agreed to acquire land from the
neighbouring landowner
owner mr keeble for this purpose however
in order to finance the project the
applicant has also included six
bungalows open market sale
ideally for over 55s wishing to downsize
this is a controversial part of the
application as i'm sure you understand
you will know that we have economic
development policies that refer to the
need to safeguard the future of local
businesses and strengthen the economy
saved policies emote1 and em20 are
unequivocal on this
the 2014 core strategy is also clear on
the need and benefit of economic growth
and talks of strengthening the rural
economy cs17 states that sustainable
tourism and leisure-based businesses
must be encouraged
mr martinson is committed to the future
of this business i think we all
recognize how difficult the past year
has been
particularly for the hospitality sector
and pubs everywhere have adopted a
variety of approaches to revitalize
their businesses
in this case the cabins have been
identified as the means for this pub to
survive and grow
although as you have heard this has been
challenged
however it is undeniable that dwellings
that is the bungalows
in this location are not supported by
policies in the mppf
the core strategy or the emerging jlp
and this is the basis for the refusal
recommendation
the applicant has stated that they are
necessary to make the project viable
and it is this that is at the heart of
whether there is a proven justifiable
need for which an exceptional
circumstance can be made
as defined in cs2 the site has been
moved further away from neighbouring
residences
since the previous application and
landscaping tree and wildfire
planting are proposed to mitigate the
impact on nearby heritage assets
and the local ecology although there are
still objections relating to these and
other aspects
there are as you've heard a number of
letters in support of the application
that focus on the economic case
but equally there is local opposition
expressing concern about the conflict
with our policies
that relate to countryside development
and also reiterating the heritage and
ecological
objections clearly if approved
conditions would need to be imposed to
resolve the land ownership matter prior
to development which
has been addressed already this morning
and also the cabins will need a
residency restriction to show that
they're not permanently occupied
if the application is not approved in
its present form then i'm sure that the
applicant will work with the local
community to see if a consensus can be
reached on the way forward
the mppf is clear about the desirability
of this
thank you chairman thank you very much
councillor ward
members have you got any questions for
the ward member
hang on a minute um i've got um
councillor hinton
followed by councillor dawson
okay pencil hinton
i thought ladies came first but not to
worry
i'm sure your hand went up first so i
was uh
normally i would go ladies first but
anyway um
yes council award you mentioned a couple
of times during the course of your uh
address there sustainability how would
you
say that these dwellings or proposed
dwellings and
holiday lodges are sustainable i was
referring to the sustainability of the
the business not
to the um uh the the uh the actual
bungalows themselves
um that obviously is a separate planning
issue concerning
um dwellings in uh a particular location
and whether that should be uh considered
sustainable or not i was talking about
the
particularly the business sustainability
and viability
ah okay you've used you've used two
abilities there yeah sustainability of
the pub is not really one of our
concerns viability
may be a consideration but
sustainability uh
is not if it counts if it's contrary to
our policies elsewhere
i i think the member has a right to
uh different points of view no i'm just
sorry it wasn't there wasn't a question
i mean i'm not uh disputing what council
hinton said
thank you all right councillor dawson
um yes i just wanted council lord so
could you just confirm
um the officers obviously their
recommendation
i'm unclear as this you said it's in
conflict with the policy cno1 of the
babylocal plan
and cs11 and cs15
the core strategy am i correct in
understanding you're supporting the
officer's recommendation in this
uh i'm supporting the fact that the
business
um needs uh to do something to to help
it
um improve and grow um
i i think in terms of how that's done
and and whether that's um
this this is the right way that's that's
for you to determine councillor dawson
yes but in this instance this is your
ward
are you supporting the officers or not
um i'm i think i'm going to come in
there councillor award i
think that's a little bit unfair because
council award did say
that if this wasn't successful
he would hope that they would continue
to talk and see whether there was an
area where
he could find uh other avenues or room
to discuss it
so i think he's saying the reasons why
he can see for it
but also i think he's saying that from
both points of view
exactly exactly and i have to
it was i can see it from both points of
view but you must have
an opinion as it's your ward i
i don't want the pub to um to fail
um but uh equally and we need to find a
way forward that
will allow it to succeed um that that
conforms with planning policies thank
you i think the league who wants to come
in
it may not be necessary i was just going
to say it's sometimes a ward counselor
who's not a voting member the committee
attends by invitation and expresses a
strong view for against it's also
perfectly profit
for them to make some points and say it
is up to the committee to decide and
i've said what i've said
yeah i i think that's what he said and i
think councillor dawson is now aware of
that
um any other questions from members
no have no other hands up cancer ward
so we'll move on thank you members we
now go to debate
so i will now open it up for debate um
is there who would like to start
uh i can't see any hens um
okay right cancel parker i was just
about to go to cancer ayers has been
at the alphabetical order right yeah
yeah
well i i mean it's just just um how to
start the debate um
uh chair really on on this one i think
um
personally can i just uh can i just come
in sorry
parker your echo in an awful lot i don't
know
whether you're you've gone to a
different room or you've locked yourself
in a cupboard or one but
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
well our mp works for military
i'm told
what i was going to say um is is that um
i i think
uh the you know the the holiday uh
the the bungalows sorry what is it we're
talking about the holiday cabins i think
in principle though those are actually
um not not a bad idea
um and i understand how they might be uh
supporting the business
um but uh the six dwellings i have to
say
i'm at a complete loss about uh in all
honesty and
um at the moment i concur wholeheartedly
with the with the officer's
recommendation on that and not
you know not not because i don't you
know dislike the the
principle of development uh at all we
don't
you know it's our job is to facilitate
um
where it's appropriate but the problem
with this application is
is that it is contrary to our current
core strategy
it is contrary to the forthcoming joint
local plan
it is in an unsustainable location it's
outside of the built-up area boundary
um and in short it's it's contrary to
everything that we've planned for
there's no guarantee it can be delivered
so to my mind chair unfortunately in
this example
i just don't think there's any
justification um
for this application and if we were to
support this application
we may as well just tear up our joint
local plan and everything
that we've been working for for the last
few years so i'm afraid it's regrettable
but at the moment that that is the
position that i'm i'm at
chairman i'll be interested to to hear
the the comments of my colleagues
thank you thank you yeah yes i think
you're uh
that's very true uh what you're saying
regarding the
holiday let's buildings um you can see
um a a reason for them but most of the
other points um
i'm inclined to agree with you um
councillor ayers
thank you chair yes i agree with um
councillor parker
and yes far more people
are going to holiday in the uk because
of
covert and all the restrictions so i
think the holiday
um homes will be lovely but again i am
rather worried about the um the
bungalows although as you
and i like bungalows that that they
would be good
um but the other thing that wasn't
mentioned is about would these bungalows
be
homes for life would there be any
special um
as in no steps or wet rooms as it's for
the over 55s which hasn't been addressed
and i would like disabled facilities to
be in the holiday let's as well
so if we could we haven't got the um
developer here have we
but there are two questions that i'd
like to have answers to
um i'll ask the officer if she can help
there but i would think if we were
minded to approve that they were
conditions we could put on but
samantha can you help answer that
question to councillor ayers
uh yeah so some of that is probably
already covered
uh under building rigs in terms of the
dwelling so
wide access points ramps up to front
doors
that kind of thing um in terms of the
holiday that's
uh it probably doesn't have the same
restrictions so that would have to be
looked at separately
the thing that you do have to bear in
mind that this is one
application so and this has been my
point all the way
through the pre-app through the previous
application
and throughout this application that the
holiday leads are probably fine
but the housing is not fine so
in terms of making a decision on the
application it has to be done as a whole
so if there's one
aspect of it that is not acceptable i'm
afraid it does have to be a refusal
it's all or nothing all or nothing thank
you
um i've got councillor
mclaren next
cool
sorry chair or something i was having
difficulty with the technology
uh my comments are similar to councillor
parker and councillor ayers
it but this business about over 55
sounds reasonable over 55s might be
able-bodied and able to drive but
over 55 can mean anything up to a
hundred
and i think for potential
owners of the properties they would be
very isolated and i in the event of the
health deteriorating i i think it is the
wrong place
for people of that age to be located
because people's health does deteriorate
however able-bodied they are when they
move into a property
but the holiday let's i have no problem
with that
thank you thank you very much um
counselor dawson
um yes i would uh concur with all the
other three i mean i must say
i i would be very concerned about
putting um an elderly person
uh in those developments i mean they
would be totally isolated
and and also it's the issue about the um
i mean i know the pub
area very well i pass it regularly and
i've been there and it's all the
the idea with the big beer garden in the
back garden
um you know if you're living in one of
those dwellings i should think that if
to someone who's sitting
living if they were built it wouldn't
really work
but i just don't think there's any
benefit for the occupants
i don't think there is also for the
surrounding hamlet i think uh mr
andrew uh renshaw was very eloquent in
his argument
um you know there's no benefit for
it's not really in keeping for the
surrounding areas
and uh why there is an argument for the
cabins
um you know that there is actually
across the road very large
uh caravan park that's very discreetly
hidden
um it is successful so
in my view i don't think there's even a
view for the caravans uh
for that and i think the only people are
really going to benefit from this are
the landowner
and the pub but i think taking into
account
the policy the occupants
the surrounding hamlet in my view um i
think miss summer's argument that far
outweighs it so um you know i i
agree with the recommendation for free
refusal sadly
thank you uh councillor plum
thank you chair i hope you can see me
okay
um yes i i think we're getting to the
stage where um
i'm i do not like being blackmailed into
to
giving planning permissions with the
bungalows um on this basis um and
and that's what i'm feeling at the
moment that that you know we're being
held
and so on i would like now at this stage
to recommend
the officer's decision of
refusal um and i would make that
proposal at this stage
thank you do i have a second a
councillor parker you'll hand us up
yeah i think that's entirely appropriate
cheryl's taking the
council of plums proposal good thank you
um any other comments
now other hands up so i
will then we've had a proposal
and a sector to accept the officer's
recommendation
and it's on the papers in front of you
um
right i'll go to claire the officer
can you take us through to the um vote
and thank you
thank you chair so members if you once
again in your mod gov app
select the plus sign on the top right
hand corner oh sorry to just to
interrupt you there
do i need to ask the planning officer
to read out the recommendation are you
all happy that you've got
it on the paperwork in front of you
i'm taking that's okay yes carry on
claire
okay thank you i will i will just
confirm it's the application dc 2004
once
be refused as detailed in the officer
recommendation
so if you go to the plus sign in your
mod gov app
select attendance and voting then select
voting and this item should now show in
light
blue and read in progress
oh sorry um
i've voted um
[Music]
against and that's that that uh
yes i suppose i should be voting for
would be for refusal of the
recommendations that's what i wanted to
do
okay in that case if i could i'll
confirm that verbally with yourself
so that's about four from councillor
beer which means
it's 10 votes for refusal
thank you
the the blue bit there was a um
something a flyer came up on the screen
just at that moment
and that pushed me arrow over
and stopped those happening when this is
going on right
now i've got to close this
all i'm not going right come
down there right i'm back on the main
screen now
so that's um decided members will move
on to item 6b which is the
warden's office sheltered hose and long
melfort
on page 31.
all right and
i'll ask the
case officer which i'll get to in a
moment
sarah scott to take us through this
sarah
if you'd like to connect up
yes thank you chair i will just share my
screen with everybody
are you seeing my screen no not at the
moment
mine's gone all yellow for some reason
but hopefully
it'll sort itself out
no just got ah
that's better yes you're there that's
fine
lovely thank you um good morning members
um i'd like to present
uh the full planning application for a
change of use and conversion of
the wardens office slash guest room
to form one unit of accommodation at
steed's meadow in long melford
so the item is brought before committee
due to the applicant being baber
and mid-suffolk district councils the
site was built
in 1985 and currently has 37
units of accommodation the site is owned
by baber district council
so this is the aerial plan you can see
that the building is an
l shape and it is located within
the residential area of long melford
again the constraints map shows
uh the main road through long melford
with list of buildings either side
the the purple area here is the
conservation area
the application site is adjacent to
the conservation area but not within
this again is is a picture of of the
site location
so the gray area here is the unit to be
converted
you can see the within the red line
there is
an area here for parking and the amenity
space
for the residents goes around the
outside
this is the existing elevations as you
can see there are
two windows and a garage door and up and
over door
so when this was used as the wardens
office this would be the designated
parking area for
the warden
so the main change to the external
appearance
is is just to remove the up and over
door
and replace it with a window which
matches in with the other two
so here we have the existing floor plans
you can see the carport in this area
here
and the lobby this is the guest room
office and a wc here this area here
is currently used for the communal
kitchen which
links into the communal sitting room
just over here on the left
the accommodation will be able to link
with the main corridor
of the accommodation
so the proposed floor plans um i think
the
the main issue here or the main change
here is
that they're going to slice a piece of
the kitchen
the communal kitchen to create
a wet room and the up and over door here
you can see has been changed to a window
which will allow the carport to become
kitchen living space
i've put the two plans on the same slide
so that you can
see the the slight changes that will
occur
internally
this is a picture from the outside so
this window here is the current window
for the communal kitchen
this is the i suppose the bedroom
office and obviously the garage door
you can see it in its context with the
rest of the building here
so this is the parking area
there are no lines within the parking
area at the moment
um but these will be demarcated just so
that
there are um extra spaces
i think it would include one extra space
which will
take a while you know allow for for the
removal of this
parking bay within this area there are
scooter storage
and bin storage
this is the view from the main street
cordle road into the site you can see
the accommodation along the back
this is a royal british legion building
here and i believe this is a medical
center here
the recommendation is approval with four
conditions as as shown here
and that's everything thank you chair
thank you thank you very much
uh members is there any points of
clarification that you'd like to ask the
case officer uh
councillor hinton i can see you've got
your hand up
thank you mr chairman yes uh again a
fairly
logical development on these on these
sites in lieu of
what's been going on with covid et
cetera so i have no problems with the
the proposals of such the
question that i brought up at the last
time we had one of these
uh was which i think was in bilderston
uh was the question of uh within the
papers where it talks about applicant
and reasons for reference to the
committee uh
this is not owned or operated by
mid-suffolk district council
it's operated by baba district council
and therefore the council own site and
applicant is the council namely baba
the only thing that we've joined
together with the two councils has been
the workforce
and if approved the local plan
every in every other respect where
separate uh constitutional entities
and certainly the property rights of our
social housing of council housing
has not been uh handed over to
mid-suffolk
you've made this point before and i
assume you're gonna get the same answer
um sarah can you um answer or mark
okay um and the site is owned by baby
district council
um i suppose the applicant when putting
in the application
put mid suffix maybe that's that's the
the council that
he's he currently works for i i don't
know i
i can't i can't answer that any any
further
thank you chair um my name is glenn
allen i'm the building surveyor who put
forward the application can i can i
answer this please
please um sarah's indeed correct i i
am an employee of mid suffolk district
council
uh although as uh councillor hinton
writer
points out this uh in effect we work
as one council in terms of
administration
although we remain separate in terms of
uh being two individual councils the
applicant
the applicant was put in as my name
specifically for the reason that i work
for mid-suffolk and that was the logical
thing to do the application is made on
behalf of baber
but it's made by me as a mid-suffolk
employee and
in fact planning rules allow any person
to make an application on somebody
else's
behalf that that doesn't prohibit that
at the end of the day the building
is as the council points out quite
correctly owned by baber and that's who
it's been done for
i'm quite sure that councillor hinton is
aware of that and
he's made the point that it is baber and
i think you've cleared that up thank you
councillor busby
yeah sarah could you go back to the
slide which shows the layout of the
the new is this one
the the floor plan so
the existing communal kitchen
is going to remain as part of a communal
kitchen for the
yes it will just be sort of separated
here
um to allow for a wet room for the unit
but this part of the communal kitchen
will remain
as communal kitchen
okay for the common room which
this door takes you into the the
communal common room which is just here
um so this is the the communal kitchen
right okay so they're not losing any
facilities no
um apparently this area of the kitchen
was underused
um so it was felt that um it would be
better used as part of this
accommodation
how convenient okay thank you councillor
osborne
thank you mr chairman just clarification
from sarah please um
this isn't uh going to be anything to do
with the
temporary uh housing accommodation it is
purely for sheltered
uh accommodation am i correct with that
yes you are
yeah i uh we have um we have transformed
some of the
furs which is in sudbury into temporary
accommodation
i haven't got no no problem with any of
this
i think it's something that is needed
and obviously i
i agree with the officer's
recommendation thank you
thank you right we're not quite there
yet councillor i was born
uh public speakers um
[Music]
long mouthful parish council um
i'm not sure whether they're present and
chair
i can confirm we don't have um
a representative from the parish council
or an objector
or a supporter and neither of the ward
members are here
and i believe officer glenn allen only
wanted to speak to answer questions he
doesn't actually need to speak i don't
know if you could
confirm that for me please glenn
yes we've done that yes i can confirm
that i'm here really swans
to answer technical questions although
if a slightly
fuller representation is required then
i'm happy to make that
right um so
there's um questions so do we have any
other public speakers
um no we don't chair none at all so we
could and with a no ward member
nope right so we're going to we get to
debate so i'll open it up who would like
to start i think it's quite
straightforward this
uh no one's uh doing anything um
well i think from the chair i'll move
the the officer's recommendation
ah cancel a plum you've got your hand up
i'll come to you
thank you oh i was gonna propose it was
you've already proposed it i'll second
it
thank you very much councillor um plum
um right
uh now go to the officer
and you'll take us through the
electronic vote
thank you chair so members uh i can see
there's a glenn allen on my screen yes
that's the officer
oh sorry yep yep that's fine okay thank
you
okay so the vote is the application
dc2100110 be approved as detailed in the
officer recommendation
members if you go to your modgov app
go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner and select attendance and
voting
then select attendance the vote is now
in progress
in a light blue color yep that's right
okay please don't any
fly-ups come on the screen all right
i've got there now
[Music]
are you saying a fly is controlling your
voting pattern no
no there's those little flying things
that keep coming on the screen telling
you things
i forget the right word and thought
pop up that's it and the last time i'd
got the fin up and that
pushed my um cursive in
across and it went on the wrong one
right so this is four
thank you chair that's 10 votes
for well done it's approved
thank you mr chairman just a quick point
the previous application we had
ten in favor uh this one we've had ten
in favor there were more than ten people
on the committee but we had no apologies
for absence
so why is there a difference we have
apologies from councillor owen
councillor hinson ah right there's 11 of
us
i missed that that's fine
this is technology councillor hinton
isn't it
uh right then we'll move on to
the next item
which will be on page
37 and it's um
officer is jasmine weiner
and it's at hadley safe
this is a display advertisement
perhaps um mr allen you can turn your
camera off
thank you and cancel the doors and you
can
turn yours off
and i'm looking for the for jasmine
yeah thank you chair and uh good morning
members i'll just share my screen
for you so just give me a second
right can you all see my screen and my
mouse
brilliant um so this application is
before the committee today
as it is a council application again um
i'll be presenting case reference dc
21 dc2100813 um
which is for the hadley pool and leisure
site located at stonehouse road in
hadley
the proposal is for the consent to
display adverts
in the form of lettering and five
panelled signs
here we have the site in context so the
site is
circled in red we've then got orange
arrows which show the separation
distances between the site and the
nearest neighbouring dwellings
the site is accessed off of stonehouse
road just to the east here and to the
north you have george street
east you have a mixture of dwellings and
a primary school just
over to the north south and west again
you've got
more dwellings and immediately
surrounding the site
is open space which is associated with
the site
then we have the constraints map so
again the site is just shown
by this hatched area uh it's within the
hadley conservation area which is shown
by this purple
and you've then got several nearby
listed buildings both grade two and
grade 2 star listed
which is shown by the orange and red
blocks over here
there's also a public right of way
running south
east of the site which is shown by the
greens or dashed line
over here
so in terms of site history in 2018
there were several extensions and works
approved as part of refurbishment of the
building
which has since been primarily completed
this application solely seeks to add
adverts to the site
um as sort of a final stage of that of
those works
uh so just for context here are the two
relevant elevations that were approved
in 2018
under that pre previous permission um
relating to the extensions
the red circles show where the proposed
efforts would be located this time which
i'll show sort of
in further detail in later slides and
it's worth noting
that the the breeze soleil over on this
top plan
um has already been approved um and the
application before you today solely
relates to putting a design
onto that approved breeze solution
it's already there um then you've also
got the bottom plan which shows the
composite lettering
and where that would be located by that
red circle there as well
so in terms of the proposed elevations
again you can see that you've got the
previously approved brief solo here
which the design i'll show you in the
next slide
um and then you've got the uh the bottom
plan again
shows the composite lettering and sort
of its position and
um depth and height um which again
relates to hadley paul and leisure
so the proposed brie soleil advert
panels are modest and have a theme that
is well related to the activities
carried out on site as you can see there
are five panels in total which are
subdivided into halves so that each half
has one word
on it
the proposed composite lettering is
modest again in appearance it's dark
gray in color
it would be illuminated but this would
be externally uh by wall wash light at
the top of this wall
just along here uh which would shine
downwards onto the letters
and would be time controlled to reduce
any impact on neighboring amenity and
unnecessary electricity usage
so the recommendation is therefore to
approve this advertisement consent
subject to the conditions within the
committee report
thank you for listening thank you
members have you got any questions
for jasmine cancer dawson
um am i right sorry
my understanding is from this is the the
lighting
um is only going to be coming on when it
sort of starts to get
dark and you alluded to
the contrary to that can you clarify
jasmine please yeah uh sorry if there's
any confusion there um
no you are you're completely right and
it's only coming on when it starts to
get dark
um so it it's primarily off
obviously during during the night when
it's not um
when the site isn't in operation
basically um and it would be time
controlled
in order so that it comes off comes on
automatically and sort of closes off
automatically
so sorry if i can just come back i mean
my understanding is because there's been
quite a lot of controversy obviously
about this in hadley
is that uh if it gets dark at say nine
or ten that's when the lights are going
to come on
isn't it
it will come on but it will be in
accordance with when the lights come on
in the adjacent car park so it will run
sort of at the same time as that and
although
yes obviously it gets dark at different
times of the year
um it will only be for the purposes
necessary for
you know people going in in and out of
the site
um and it won't be any any
further lighting and you know light
pollution than what is already there in
terms of these street lights in the
adjacent car park
thank you yes and also if i could just
sorry come at the second question am i
correct in saying this is in a
conservation area
yep yes it is thank you
thank you um right is there
any other questions i can't say another
hands uh counselor hinton
yes just a quick one um brie
soleil is um obviously it sounds french
um
so obviously it's left over from norman
times but uh are those panels
illuminated or are they just painted
panels that
are put up in that location
uh thank you council engine yet they are
completely unilluminated
um they are just just basically the
lettering and the design that's going on
them
um the only light that you would see
sort of coming from that direction
would be any light that submitted from
the actual building itself
not from the bristol lane
thank you
right uh councillor busby
he showed us the at the lay and the
panels independently have you got a
picture where they're
together um unfortunately
there wasn't anything submitted which
shows them together um but i suppose if
i go
back to um just so you can still see it
again bear with me
um so as you can see there's sort of
these five distinct panels
which then match up to the five panels
here
so where they're sort of halved in the
center that's basically where these are
halved but they they form one panel as a
whole um
it's just for the purposes of the design
as you can see it's sort of split
for each of the letters basically well
the words even
sorry can you go back to the previous
slide yep
so is it me being thick are you saying
that they're going to go over the
the bruise soleil or they're going in
these white boxes beneath them
so sorry it's these little bits here
that's the the brie soleil which is
where that that
artwork is basically going um
so what why are we covering it over
um i'm not sure if kate might be able to
to answer that as she's sort of been
quite involved in the project
okay can you help us sorry i've just
literally joined peter um sorry cancer
can we just repeat the question for me
sorry so i know what i'm answering
thank you what why are we covering the
breeze to lay up with these panels
no the pan they're not the panels are
the bracelet
there's no panels covering the bristle
well slide seven then if it's not a
panel slide
seven sorry i've not seen
so those are the that is the bruce delay
those panels are the free slay that's
the image that will be the bruce lee
can you just clarify where that is on
slide six
yep so where the
thank you jasmine the whole thing
that all of them are in that first
little depart part
yes there's five of them right so
there's five of them so the image
um so i keep moving my calendar and the
images are those five panels that is the
bracelet they're not panels in sense of
being covered that is the image
obviously it's not the image that we're
having but jasmine's trying to
demonstrate
the image of that where it'll be does
that make sense so there's nothing there
at the moment
no and we need it for the glare
particularly
around the glare through from the
sunlight um into the pool as well so
one is is obviously going to be
physically pleasing but two there is an
issue around the glare into the pool
around
sunlight and and and things sorry
okay right thank you
all right thank you there's no more
hands up
uh yes oh yours is right cancel the door
if i can come back for clarification on
this again um
i'm not against the brisley per se you
know i understand when you're swimming
up down
one needs that the issue with this and i
wonder if you can clarify this
is it's the fact that it's 20 basically
this is going to end up being a 20 meter
long
advertising hoarding that is lit up at
night
that is my but we can't separate can we
can we have the bracelet without the
lighting because my understanding is we
can't with this or can we
um so the breeze lays completely
unilluminated
yes but they are in this one of the the
main objection is
is at night you're going to be switching
on lights and we're going to have this
20 meter panel
that's going to be um you know seen for
miles around
i think this might that is that's the
understanding of it this is going
in fact we have lost you may i respond
cancel a beer
see the bracelet is not eliminated at
all the illuminations to do with the
sign saying
i think it um the sign for the the
center itself
um so the breeze lay itself it doesn't
have any illumination it's whatsoever it
is
is aesthetically pleasing but also to
help with the glare the the lighting
that they're referring to and got
illumination has to do with the sign
and that will be in line with the street
lighting that's already in the car park
in timings so will the lighting inside
the swimming pool
area be shining there sorry chair
it's claire can i just confirm that we
have councillor dawson back because if
she's not saying anything
yeah did you miss anything there
councillor dawson i need you to
okay so if kate could repeat her last
reply
just so that counselor dawson's got all
of the information
of course um so the brief slate itself
will not be illuminated there will
obviously be lights
in the swimming pool when swimming pools
on but it won't be officially
illuminated with pacific lights for the
breeze soleil
um the illumination will be is attached
to
purely the the signage for the the
center
which will be it with timings as the car
park lighting is so it won't be any
additional lighting that
already happens in that location no but
the point is
if i may sorry is uh the general
objection is people don't want this
light this panel which is going to is
separate the lighting is separate to the
car park i mean people moan about the
car park
you've got to have lighting there but
it's the idea that it's sort of eight or
nine o'clock at night
that the lighting comes off but that's
it inside the building
no it's it's mine saying is it that it's
like an advertising hoarding this isn't
it
it's going to be coming on at night to
advertise when actually nobody goes
swimming after nine o'clock ten o'clock
at night
and uh whilst it's on a timer the point
i mean
could i could we do it um could i
suggest then then it's done
illuminated let's get answers to your
questions first
we need to clear up this point that
they're not illuminated
that the lights are only on inside the
building
is that correct kate in regards to the
breeze slay yes that's correct that the
breeze
does not have its own illumination at
all it'll only be if the swimming pool
is on that you would have light coming
from the
building as you already do have um yes
but it's night time
this is misleading at night time you're
going to be having a 20 meter
if the lights are turned on
i'll let you come in on those points
when we get into debate
okay because that's been clarified so
we've got to accept that
it's already there that the lights are
inside the build and not
illuminating the signs um so we can pick
you can pick that point up in debate and
then the officers can
can answer it um i've still got two
hands up john hinton
kenzel hinton and kenzler busby is that
correct
yeah right thank you very much
am i going to um thank you mr chairman
yeah as i understand it then the the
question of
illumination is relative to the hadley
pool and leisure sign
and the breeze soleil is only
illuminated
through backlighting from within inside
the pool
itself is that correct yeah that's
that's completely correct so the will
effectively as councillor dawson says be
a 20
foot long illuminated sign even if it's
only backlit from inside the pool
so what what we're considering today is
solely the graphic design that's going
on the breeze soleil
the notion of the bruce lay and the
glare coming
from the existing building was approved
in 2018
we're only looking at the actual design
that is going
on to the brisley
um i can see is um does
the chief plan officer want to come in
mark
thank you chair yeah i think that
jasmine has just said what i was going
to say this is an advertisement
application
so the breeze soleil was put up as part
of a previous permission i think
actually
theoretically it might be able to
something like put up without permission
because it's a part 12 of the
general development or it's a local
government thing so anyway it's got
permission the bruce lay as a structure
has got permission this is an
advertisement only application so it's
it's the
it's the wording and the images that
you've seen plus
any lighting which is there to show that
up that is the advertisement application
not the bracelet itself and not the
lighting inside the building
no no no the lighting's already there if
it's as part if it's part of an
application to light some words up
then then yes but if the lighting's
already there then no
well we've been told this isn't so that
can be clarified
picked up in debate uh thank you for
that mr russell
uh there's no other hands up
um and my screen is playing up
i've lost um right we're going to public
speakers but um
i can't find them at the moment but i
think we've got the town council
wishing to speak is that correct claire
can you just help me out here
yes yes chair we have carol schleip
from the town council uh right what if
carol
slope if you like to join and
turn your camera on and your mic and
perhaps um
jasmine you can take down your um
sharon
okay good morning good morning sorry
about that
i've i've got my name back now um
yep your time will start when you start
speaking okay
thank you very much good morning um
howdy town council
um really welcomes the very considerable
investment
made by baber in this facility
um with a bit of a top-up from the town
council of two hundred thousand
it's a fantastic facility for hadley um
and i'd also like to thank the officers
of baby district council
who've delivered this project probably
against a very difficult um
backdrop of covid um so i'm therefore a
bit sort of disappointed to
make an objection on the final stage of
the project
regarding the signage um
it's a bit confusing i think we're all a
bit confused with the
answers that we've been given this
morning um it seems to me
that the in the planning application the
signs would be lit from sort of
even perhaps from inside the building
from 0 5
4 5 hours to twenty to thirty hours
seven days a week um i think that was in
the
application and i accept it's gonna be
different in the summer to the winter
but potentially it's going to be there
you know for
quite a lot of the time um i think
it's also considered i think locally
there's there's already enough light
over the sort of the porch
um which you know can you know can be
seen
and the area is already well lit um
and this the sort of um impact
of more illuminated signs or
whatever um is unnecessary
and you know we've also declared a sort
of a climate emergency i know baby has
and with suffolk i don't know um haditha
council has um but i think you know
neighbours
are concerned um it is in a conservation
area there are a lot of buildings in the
area
um there's always going to be a lot of
light from the car park
which i think is sort of understandable
because obviously
it's going to be used by the public and
you've got a duty of care there
um so really i have
an objection about the the lighting
and the length of time it's going to be
there
you know it's 5 45 to 22
30. um and really and that's all i need
to sort of
to say but thank you very much for
giving me the opportunities
to put my views across thank you i'll
serve as any questions for you
members is any hands going up
nope thank you very much then um
right we'll carry on if you'd like to
turn your camera and um
mike off uh i'm not sure if we've got an
objector
or supporter or the agent
no chair we haven't right so we'll then
go right down
to the ward members and i'm not sure we
have
um them is councillor brandon with us
uh she's not chair but she has uh
confirmed
via email that she has no objections to
the application
and we don't have councillor fraser with
us today either we've not had anything
from him
thank you right so we can't do questions
to them so we're now in debate members
uh right who would who would like to
start
this is a um application for an
advertisement consent uh councillor
dawson
yes i suppose i should thank thank you
carol for eloquently again um for your
discussion on this it's tricky this one
because as a swimmer and i am the hadley
north member
um there is a great deal of um locally
people just don't see the point in baber
putting a sign up to advertise they feel
it's not really necessary
and i have to say i'm inclined to agree
with this um
it's also in a conservation area you
know
uh local residents are really i'm quite
upset about it all because they've got
all the lighting there for the car park
um the panel can be seen quite clearly
um in daylight do we need a neon light
20 meters long
um being lit up at night to advertise it
i i can't really see the logic of doing
it so
um you know we've it's got the
permission for the breeze to lay but i
don't think advertising is really
necessary
um in the conservation area in the
evening
um so i i i have to agree with the town
council and with local residents i
wouldn't really support this
well thank you very much that's
understandable um
councillor i was born i did see you come
up but have you gone again
oh no i'm still there just uh right
no that's fine um there is only one
option to this
from from dawson's point of view and
that is
you don't have the lights on in the
inside the building
to light that screen up big i agree
and if you if you've got lights inside
the building whether the signage up
or not you've still got lights coming
through so
you either put a blinder over the top of
the whole lot
to to come off at the time the lights
come on
the only bit of advertising that's
coming on
is actually the lighting for hadley paul
leisure's uh position
so you know let's you know let's get
let's get real with this
if you don't want the light in you've
got to turn the building the lighting
off inside the building
thank you uh councillor busby
just a quick question what will the
panel be made of what kind of material
if kate might be able to answer that
i can kate can you help
yeah it's a type of plastic um i can get
into more specifics but it is a
type of plastic that is kind of that has
got the ability to be kind of
it's slightly transparent um that is
then plugged into some metal
fasteners um but it's being printed on
for us sorry it will diffuse the light
it will kill a lot of the light that
would normally be there if it was just
windows yes so it's not it's not glass
um it is plastic um and it is quite
quite colorful so again you know
regarding how much light will come
through
there's a reasonable color within the
panels to like say diffuse some of the
light
yeah and glare thank you
councillor mclaren
sorry um
when we when we no in normal planning
applications
we're able to ask the applicant the
applicant is babura district council
is it remiss of me to ask who
in babur district council requested this
application and what what was the
reasoning behind the application who in
the council
requested it
uh that's a good point uh can
jasmine can you help us out is this part
of the
um normal application do you mean
in in terms of why have we got this
application for adverts
or who no is responsible
right jasmine what i'm asking is baber
district council is quite
a large group of people which
department felt it was necessary to put
this application to the planning
committee got mark here i think i think
he might be able to help us
yeah i mean first of all it's at
committee because it's baby's
application that's the reason but the
in terms of questions about where it's
come from what it's needed for and all
of that
kate parnum's here she's spoken a couple
of times so she may be able to help you
councillor mclaren thank you kate can
you help
hi yeah so i'm i work in the economic
development team uh this project started
before i was involved um chris frye um
brought it full to committee to get the
funding to
get the application for this so you know
the original application around the
breeze delay and
and the signage was always part of that
cabinet report that was degreed on
i think four years ago three years ago
um all i've done
is just picked up the last bit of the
application because obviously
advertisements on our building
and therefore has to come to committee i
think normally wouldn't necessarily have
to come to committee it'd be an officer
decision because obviously whether
we're the owner as it were and it had to
come to yourself so debris soleil
was agreed at both um formal counsel
as well as obviously planning about
having the bruce lay and there's
a a new sign as it were because there's
obviously original sign on there i'm i'm
saying there's an issue about the
lighting
but um that's where it's come from can i
also ask another question okay
was there um so was there the you say
the original
sign where was i mean i can understand
having a sign saying hadley leisure
center
i accept that but was there an original
one that's been
sort of is there or is being replaced
yeah so the original one is um i can
show an image of that if that would be
helpful of what it was
originally if that makes any sense yeah
um it was quite tired and dated and
obviously we just invested as you can
imagine
two new you know 2.2 million in this
building and it
felt that um because it's got a more
focus on swimming i suppose you know
we've just put in a very nice swimming
pool
that the name change and just to make it
very clear about what's actually at that
center because not
not all legends have some important as
as you you will know
so it was really important to advertise
the the investment we had and that
there's a lovely
swimming pool there but i'm if it
helpful i can send the image to jasmine
to share
if that helps what the original sign
looked like if that was no no no
it was just that um obviously
yeah the replacement um and so you've
got you've you've you know told me that
so that's
that's fine thank you thank you chair
mark did you want to come back or chair
may i suggest
if it's all right with you can jasmine
just spell out again exactly what is
being proposed here because obviously
some things are mixed up with what's
already got permission i wonder if
members might benefit from just a
two-minute run through exactly what the
proposal is remembering it it's an
advertisement application
and that's all we're looking at so i'll
let jasmine just quickly run through a
key slides again that's okay
that's a time convenient to you yeah no
no um i'll just i've got
um still two hands up sean dorse and
dane busby but i think they're old hands
or aren't they
old hands right yes um jasmine if you'd
like to take us through and explain
exactly what we're being asked to
agree or not agree to yeah okay if i
just share my screen again because that
might just
help visualize it
right can you see my screen yes
brilliant right so if i go so this was
the 2018 permission
and the permission related to extending
and sort of refurbing
the whole existing hadley pool and
leisure facility
as part of this application a brie
soleil
was approved so this application is
solely for
what the design that is going on to the
uh brie soleil and for hadley paul and
leisure
to go here so if we just see
so the panels there are five panels here
which would have a design on the breeze
soleil
has already got permission so
technically could be put there
without you know us approving or
refusing this today
um it's solely just what is actually on
that bruce delay
um you've then got the hadley paul and
leisure sign on this front here
the sign itself is unilluminated
there would be a if i just go here
there is a light at the top here which
faces downwards
onto this sign and that
that's it um
so in terms of the lighting that's there
will be an element of lighting already
coming from the building but that has
already been approved in 2018
likewise any glare coming from the bruce
lay is from
the um the building itself
rather than actually being emitted from
anything that we're considering today
all right thank you councillor i was
born
thank you mr chairman i just just want
to get the clarification
so that everybody understands it those
pictures you've just seen
show the south west i think and the
northeast so they're two different
elevations of the building
so it you you know somebody or
some uh members are looking at the
position that they're both coming from
the same position
they're not perhaps that should be
clarified a little bit better
all right thank you yes there's two two
sides uh councillor plum
thank you chair let can i i'm just going
to make that point that
council has just made but also um the
sign
over the hadley pool etc that light
already exists
is that correct
jasmine or kate i think i'd probably
need to ask
kate i'm not sure that the light over
that already exists but certainly the
signage there is some signage there
kate can you help yes um
the sign is a sign is there but it's not
lit as such
at the moment um so and so that is
additional
and can i come back on that and is that
next to the entrance to the pool
the front entrance is that is that the
main entrance
is that the main entrance should i share
and my screen again just so you can see
the elevation well no we just need to
know whether that's the main entrance
uh i'd like that
back so this
is where the entrance is that
that's the hadley pool and leisure this
face is this elevation faces onto the
existing car park
which is where there's already street
lights and whatnot there
um this elevation is on the opposite
side to that so it's basically flipped
around as you can sort of see by the
elevations
um and faces onto the open space that
surrounds
um the the building and then obviously
there's a
set of dwellings there but those
dwellings facing that side are actually
further away than the ones that face
sort of north um
which is sort of over here so
that's that's pretty much it really
okay thank you
so that the only thing that is a light
is already in the car park area and is
only
going to be on at the same time as the
car park lights
and and it also illuminates the front
entrance
which otherwise might be a rather dark
hole
and in terms of personal safety it's a
good thing
okay okay
thank you councillor dawson oh yes kate
could you be so kind to put that photo
up again the one you just showed us of
um
yeah of course bear with me uh the one
prior to that
uh sorry back again the one you showed
of the you brought up
number seven isn't it that one yes now
am i
my understanding is here there is subtle
lighting from inside this
pool that is going through that window
and outside of that window there is more
lighting that's lighting up the signage
this isn't a window this is so
yes but where the um where those panels
are that are see-through
on the exterior of the building there is
lighting advertising
lighting up those panels the lighting
from inside
is you know subtle lighting coming
through that's fine
but uh cancel the doors and we've just
got to be clear
slide um you can go back to that slide
that was
on uh the other one
that the next that one that one
is um there's no lighting behind that
or anything it just comes down from the
top uh so
that that isn't the one that you're
referring to because
um and now if we go to slide seven
this is the one i think you're referring
to now
yes and that there is lighting outside
the building
there um which is
coming on which is the is what all the
residents
this is my understanding is not
acceptable
so there's only there's only lighting
that's being proposed on this
application
that is at the top of this wall here
there is no lighting on this side at all
right so we're clear the only light and
is from
inside the pool yep so
so there's none on the outside
councillor dawson kenzler parker you're
next
um yeah thank you chad you know just
really as
a committee member from you know looking
for me outside in just to say that we're
not making a
fist
you know purely reading from the report
4.0 paragraph 4.2 on page 42
gives assurances around the lighting
when it's going to be when it isn't
going to be on
paragraph 7 to 7.2 on page 43 covers the
heritage issue
and uh most personally paras eight
to eight point three cover the impact on
residential amenity
um i don't know you know we spent 2.2
million pounds on this
on this unit um chair um i i don't know
why we're having such an extensive
debate about it i i for one have
absolutely no issues with it
um uh even to the extent that i'm
actually happy to
propose that we accept the officer's
recommendation
much for um thank you uh very helpful
um do i have a second to fire it yes
right cancel a plum um did you want to
make it pass any comment no other then
let's get on with it we're spending far
too much
time debating something which is
should doesn't need any further debate
right and i'm inclined to agree with you
i i think members we have had quite a
debate on this
um it is quite clear it's on page 45 the
recommendation
to grant and there's one two three
four five six seven eight nine um
comments there conditions um so
i think it's all catered for uh
councillor hinton until your hands come
up i don't know if it's an
old one right yeah i agree with
i agree with the fact that we're it's
been proposed in second dead
um but i think a lot of this confusion
could have been
uh avoided if we'd had some photographs
of the building because that would have
more clearly shown what was going on
rather than trying to interpret a
2d uh representation in the drawing
concur with that john actually
because right thank you i think you've
made your point we can all be wise
afterwards
uh but i'm sure the officers have um
noted that point
um but i i think i'm going to suggest
that we now go to the vote
so i'm going to ask claire to read out
the recommendation
and then take us through to the vote
thank you chair
so the vote is the application dc 2100
be approved as detailed in the officer
recommendation
members that boat is now in progress if
you select the plus sign
on your mod gov app select attendance on
voting
and then voting and
this vote is now showing in progress in
a light blue color
yes
just waiting for one vote to her
hopefully not mine i think
no right that's um that's all the votes
in thank you that's 10 votes
for chair so that is carried
thank you very much well members we've
got to the end of today's meeting
um so thank you all very much for that
um just to remind you the date and time
of the next meeting is scheduled
for wednesday the 5th of may at 9
30. hopefully there won't be too many
items on the agenda
but um your attendance is required
okay i'd like to declare the meeting